china enfrenta una crisis
multidimensional agravada entre otros
factores por la pandemia de kobe 19 algo
que tiene en alerta al gobierno liderado
por siguen pin que mantiene una estricta
política de cero tolerancia con el virus
esto ha generado el temor incertidumbre
en toda la población además del impacto
económico por los confinamientos
obligatorios que ha dejado a
trabajadores en cuarentena durante meses
en varias ciudades a esto se suma el
reciente desplome del sector
inmobiliario que casi provocó la quiebra
de uno de los mayores constructores del
país hablamos de evergrande desde 2013
el gigante asiático ha invertido cerca
de 800 o 40 mil millones de dólares en
la construcción de calles puertos
también represas y plantas de energía en
diversas partes del mundo pero son cada
vez más países que piden una prórroga
crediticia porque no pueden pagar estas
deudas como si fuera poco la crisis
climática también se suma a estos
problemas para el gobierno la ola de
calor y la sequía inédita en décadas
continúa azotando al centro de esta
nación mientras que en el oeste son las
inundaciones las que causan estragos
hasta el momento 23 personas fallecidas
salvamos en este momento angélica guerra
varón ella es doctora en ciencia
política con énfasis en relaciones
internacionales profesora de tiempo
completo de la universidad científica
del sur gracia angélica por estar con
nosotros entregará tica de francés de
4ta mañana gracias vamos a hablar
entonces de dos años después del inicio
de la pandemia la política cero de
covite 19 por parte del gobierno de jean
ping se mantiene en ese país porque las
autoridades digamos se resisten a
relajar estas estas medidas y digamos no
quieren convivir con el virus como lo
está haciendo el resto del mundo que tan
dañino además puede ser esta política si
lo es para la población y para la
economía de ese país bueno raúl
realmente tiene mucha lógica desde una
perspectiva doméstica que las
autoridades chinas decidan ser tan
estrictas con el manejo de este tipo de
medidas para la salubridad pública si
nosotros recordamos en donde empezó
donde se dio el brote que luego en una
pandemia luego de la declaración de la
ms tiene demasiada razón que
utilicen este tipo de herramientas si se
quiere demasiado controladoras para la
población por supuesto que las
autoridades en beijing están muy
preocupadas por el asunto ellos no
quieren ver un nuevo rebrote hemos visto
que el número de casos por el coi de 19
ha aumentado y no quieren ver nuevamente
que la economía de su país se vea
afectada desde una perspectiva negativa
ha sido han sido varias las políticas y
las herramientas digamos las estrategias
que los gobiernos locales han
implementado pero nosotros no debemos
perder de vista que la república popular
china es regida por un sistema poco
democrático y bastante arreglado desde
beijing si entonces estas dinámicas
desde el centro por supuesto que van a
afectar toda la toma de decisiones
al interior del país
creo que tiene mucho mucho sentido si tú
lo analizas desde una perspectiva
doméstica más que todo claro pero
digamos que el impacto con micro también
se siente pues y también el impacto
general en la población digamos hemos
visto escenas de caos por ejemplo en una
guía cuando se registró un caso que la
gente salió despavorida para que
precisamente no los confinaron también
como esto afecta a la salud de la
población en general y también la de la
economía muchos comerciantes pues han
tenido que cerrar obligatoriamente o sea
es algo que impacta también en la
economía dentro de la propia china por
supuesto a ver si nos ponemos a pensar
cuáles son las formas a través de las
cuales las autoridades están manejando
este fenómeno podría decirse que va en
contra de los mismos derechos humanos
porque las personas básicamente son
internadas como si estuvieran en un
centro carcelario sin desde esa
perspectiva ahora económicamente por
supuesto que hay un impacto y un poco
enlazándolo con el tema central que tú
estabas mencionando hace un rato el
impacto se siente demasiado cuando
estamos mirando a las personas a la
población en general y esto se aprecia
demasiado bien el sector inmobiliario si
nosotros hacemos ese enlace si traemos
esa variable o esa ficha podemos
comprender que el sector inmobiliario no
solamente es importante para la economía
china el sector inmobiliario representa
más los otros sectores asociados el 30%
del producto interno bruto o sea no es
cualquier cosa no es un sector de menor
importancia entonces tienes todo todo el
sentido para mencionarlo hay un efecto
los ciudadanos se están viendo afectados
por esto económicamente se está hay
mucho temor y hay mucha incertidumbre de
parte del mercado porque los mercados se
mueven por incertidumbres o por
seguridades en este caso no no la veo
mucho con demos en ese en esa crisis el
mercado inmobiliario digamos que podemos
estar ad portas de una recesión
inmobiliaria una crisis inmobiliaria
mejor dicho dentro de china a cuenta de
eso también muchísimos personajes china
han dejado a pagar sus hipotecas sus
créditos de mobiliarios por precisamente
pues todas estas medidas del coi 19
otros factores que ha afectado
sobre todo a la gigante everbank qué va
a pasar con este sector inmobiliario
realmente se puede desplomar o si el
gobierno chino digamos puede hacer una
reestructura como ya lo anunciado y
puede rescatarlo mira en realidad es muy
interesante si uno mira en un corto
lapso de tiempo lo que ha pasado con
esta inmobiliaria ya veníamos viendo una
declinación en términos de la inversión
pública en el sector inmobiliario chino
básicamente desde enero del año 2020
nosotros podemos apreciar cómo se da la
caída es una caída que no tiene ninguna
interpretación distinta a eso en este
sentido el gobierno
chino al inicio trató de mostrar o de
enviar un mensaje positivo para todos
indicando que podría ser un caso aislado
y que sería un evento que no tendría
mayores repercusiones sin embargo esto
se ha mostrado muy distinto la caída de
la segunda empresa inmobiliaria más
grande de china que es éver grandes como
tú lo han señalado por puesto que pone
nerviosos a muchos
y la búsqueda de dinero para poder pagar
las deudas que ha adquirido esta gran
empresa inmobiliaria es una gran señal
es una señal evidente que debe cumplir o
debe pagar sus deudas que equivalen ya a
300 billones de dólares o sea el hecho
de que una empresa como ésta tenga más
de 1000 subsidiarias y tenga proyectos
en 300 ciudades aproximadamente de china
nos hace pensar y nos hace ver que hay
ahí hay que hacer un cambio en el
mensaje y en el relato del gobierno y
eso lo vemos cuando hace poco el
gobierno decide emitir una ley donde se
pone un tope un límite a las empresas
inmobiliarias chinas este es un mensaje
claro donde dicen evergrande puede ser
grande pero también deben tener cuidado
porque el gobierno chino no puede
regalarlos en todo angélica no quiero
que eso quede por afuera el tema de la
crisis climática el impacto de las
sequías y las inundaciones también que
agravan evidentemente este este problema
económico digámoslo así que puede tener
chinas
bueno mira sin duda este es un tema que
a nivel global no se puede ocultar no
podemos decir que haya un país más o
menos responsable me explico un poco a
la final hay una cierta
carga en frente de todos para poder
lidiar con el cambio climático y los
fenómenos de variabilidad climática
también obviamente que china si nosotros
nos ponemos a ver la producción de gases
de efecto invernadero
tiene un efecto negativo a nivel
climático y tiene mucha razón
lógico parece muy lógico que en china se
estén dando estos eventos que afectan
por supuesto la salubridad de todas las
personas y más en un país donde es bien
sabido raúl que los estándares de
protección al medio ambiente no se
cumplen como debería ser entonces nada
vienen más retos complejos porque la
capacidad de producción de china si bien
ha disminuido a partir del coi y todos
los efectos de los que estamos hablando
pues se va a ver también reflejado
negativamente en la parte medioambiental